San Francisco I'll be back Friday
December 8th and Saturday December 9th
at Cobbs Comedy Club it's the last stop
of the live and Alive tour for 2023 get
your tickets at Ryan
sickler the honey do with Brian
[Music]
[Applause]
sichler welcome back to the the Honeydew
y'all we're over here doing it in the
night pants Studios I am Ryan sickler
Ryan sickler docomond sickler on all
your social media I'm going to start
this episode like I start every episode
by saying thank you whether you're new
here or whether you've been here whether
you go back to the feast or whether you
roll with the de thank you for your
support please subscribe to the uh
channel it's a free way to help I'm
telling you they're censoring everybody
you all know it out there they're not
kicking it out anymore so subscribe
cribe it's a free way to help the show
and then if you got to have more I am
telling you I tell you every week if you
thinking fine like I'm going to give it
a chance the patreon is called the
Honeydew it's this show with y'all all
right and I promise you it's five bucks
a month and you don't just get one
episode or that month you get the entire
library and you will never hear [__]
like you hear on that patreon I
guarantee it best five bucks you ever
spend all right you sign up for a month
you get I mean a year excuse me you over
a month free all right so um if you're
looking for a new podcast to listen to
go listen to my old podcast to crab
Feast Jay Larson and I did it was seven
and a half year library and that library
is going to do over a million downloads
this year that's how strong you guys
still are out there so it's audio it's
got everyone you know and love and
podcasting with different stories all
right come see me on tour December 8th
and 9th we're closing out in San
Francisco California we'll get you new
dates for 20 24 for later but for now
that's the business you know what we're
doing over here we're highlighting the
low lights I always say these are the
stories behind the storytellers I very
glad to have this guest back on the
Honeydew y'all three time audio two time
video ladies and gentlemen Prof is
back I just ran into our boy Barry D's
in uh Tula who's the guy that originally
he does the graphics for the show
originally tagged you and put the music
who introduced me to you and then that
was really I told him I was like that
was the beginning of realizing like how
many of our fans really were crossover
cuz you never know you know it's it's
like two different sports you know it's
it's football and baseball they're two
different things com see both oh you
guys [__] with each other oh man all
right they love When 2p2 Worlds Collide
like that and connect so so I'm glad to
have you back um we're going to get into
it but before we talk about we're going
to talk about plug promote whatever you
want I know you love to be nothing
nothing I know you
you know what the [__] the deal is
what's the tour what's the new tour
called what's the tour called the one
you're on right now a high price shoes
tour high price shoes yeah high price
shoes to I'm um that was like my last
music video was a song called high price
shoes and is that the one you had Kim
and Sarah in no that was Judy Judy my
mother's name no is that what it was
called dude yeah yeah had Kim [__] we
flew down here and um we had to did in
court in a courtroom and there was no
there's not a set that big in the
midwest so we like is it downtown in
that building that like 1111 building
downtown it's got all those different
rooms a bunch of different like a DMV
and shits in there there's a bunch of
[__] in there so that was really cool
very very professional like that was my
first experience with like because we
just do it in Minnesota usually and it's
just a bunch of people like trying their
best you know what I'm saying but um
same director and everything but his his
help his cast of characters were like
pros they're all like oh I was on this
video I was in this movie blah blah blah
all the actors are all you know got
their sheets and stuff and it was it was
a crazy big uh production so it cool so
go check Prof out on tour for sure um
and I'm glad you're still doing it
because I want to talk to you
specifically about what happened to you
I'm you're lucky to be alive for real
I'm I'm almost dying in January in the
hospital on my back clot it up yeah I
was talking to you through that whole
experience because I you know I had a
back uh uh surgery too so I'm like yeah
and I was checking in on you and then it
just kept getting worse bro it was good
dude I was supposed to have Robert Kelly
who I still I can't wait to get you on
here Bobby Kelly uh on here and I kept
telling him I was texting him like dude
I'll be out in two days I'll be out in
two more days and I'm like I almost died
I don't know what's going on you were in
there for so [__] long yeah almost a
month I was in there it's like over 3
weeks and and uh did it just get I mean
I cled that was what it was it was my
back was fine except there was a small
tear and they fixed it and they're like
all right now just lay and chill and the
laying and chilling oh you think caused
that
[__] none all this was a medical mistake
on Cedar SI part I and and all the
surgeons yeah all the surgeons I need
help all the surgeons came in and told
me this was a mistake this shouldn't
happen it I what happened to me wasn't
because of Lifestyle wasn't like you're
eating uh improperly you're not
exercising you're smoking too much or
drinking none of that it was are you
anything we'll talk off we'll talk off
Mike we'll talk off Mike into it
sometimes it's just more uh look here's
the thing I'm going to say this that's
exactly right I I don't care how much
it's worth in the in the state of
California they cap it anyway it's
$250,000 that's what you're entitled to
that's it if they [__] that's it okay
now if what if they just paralyze
somebody if you're well then there then
there there's tears I'm the guy that get
to 250 if there's a pregnancy if there's
a death if there's a then it's it goes
up but you're Capp at
250 though yeah if you like someone
accidentally impregnate somebody well I
mean they could accident someone could
be pregnant and then they [__] up the
baby okay yeah then there's more money
accidental pregnancy yeah accidental
[__] up to pregnancy okay uh but anyway
I don't want to spend a year and a half
of my life going to court exactly
dealing with this [__] and I don't care
how much money it's wor I'm not going to
I'm not going to no I'm not I don't I
don't want to I really don't I have no
interest in it because I know what it is
they're they're like look you're going
to have to find a medical professional
who's going to go against everybody and
say yeah they and first of all good luck
doing that then you got to come in and
do your deposition I don't want to spend
any more energy I'm glad to be here I I
mean it'd be nice if y all paid my
medical bills I shouldn't have to come
out of pocket for the minimum I would
like that done other than that I don't
give a [__] about this 250 or any of
that number it's fake it's not real and
in the end it'll be like you're going to
get $88,000 like I just spent a year and
a half of my life for that [__] that
that's n um but let's talk about you cuz
as I'm in there laying there and they're
telling me I might die I'm looking on
social media and seeing you might
[__] die and I'm like what the [__]
going on yeah hold up to that camera
right here look at that [__] dude it is
so I I get looks at like restaurants and
[__] people are like
oh you know what I'm saying yeah I'm
like no yeah we watch like [__] I'm
happy look at that yeah it's [__]
very obvious tell us what
happens tell us exactly how it happened
that's what they said at the hospital
too like do you going hurt yourself do
you have feelings are you suicidal I'm
like no and then finally um uh the ER
doctor recognized me oh what's up bro
hell you know what I'm saying so I'm
like dude where were you tell me
everything okay so you're on the road
I'm doing a show in Atlanta okay doing a
show in
Atlanta um and after the shows I like to
take a shower on the bus because I'm
just [__] drenched you've seen the
shows and I'm like stick you're one of
the best live performers I've ever seen
I tell everybody that it is true you can
say that it is true um so I'm I usually
take a well every every show I take a
shower and I'm taking a shower and
usually I'm on the bus like alone no
one's usually back there or whatever
luckily um my DJ Wonka and my homie Cody
was on the bus and usually there's not
anybody in the bus so I'm taking a
shower and the shower head is just
leaking off the connection more than the
actual shower so I'm like actually
showering with like a broken connection
I'm like this shit's stupid whatever I
take my shower but that at the end I
look back in there I'm still naked and
[__] I'm like let me let me tighten this
connection and I'm sitting there
tightening the connection and it just
goes and it just breaks it fails and it
just go like this oh so it's sliced
under like that it went one one side
went like this and and it just like that
and it didn't it didn't break at the
thread of the at the thread it broke at
like the cast so like the aluminum cast
of the uh broke and you could feel it I
kept it for a keep sake you can touch
it's a razor blade ra like sharper than
a razor blade like you can touch a razor
blade and not get cut this thing is
going to cut you even if you touch it
and so and do you feel it right away I
don't feel nothing it's so quick and it
was so sharp and clean I just go and a
spray of blood like fine Mist comes out
and I'm
like and I look at it and what it look
like before that what do you see it was
it was it was way wide open all the way
wide open all the way wide open what do
you see you seeing tendons and [__] dude
bro it wasn't even bloody yet like it
was all the white meat and like look at
I mean if you can seen this camera like
look at all of the things in there yeah
look at all the muscles and [__] that
move and everything it look like that's
why people go for that spot to kill them
so it seeing that it burned in my
standing there burned all the white
stuff there's white things and then like
so yeah so my first thing is just going
like
this no
nuh total disbelief
like way worse than anything I could
imagine what it just looked [__]
awful and I put my hand on it and I'm
like no [__] way no [__] way and
it was just so I just had I spent a
second I was just thinking about it and
I'm
like but you know what I'm
saying uh look at it
then this is how my my mind is going I'm
like well then just check and then my
mind goes ain't no [__] way I'm
letting go of my hand so then I was like
all right yeah because like because I'm
not letting go I know I know it's
[__] real is blood dripping out from
under that at this point when you're
holding it like that I went really quick
like it
was really quick so like less maybe even
less than a second you know but there
was there was there was blood coming
under it and stuff like that and then uh
and it's sprayed [__] that dude yeah
like fine like like when I went back in
the shower you could see it wasn't like
a lot because I I I got it right away
but it it it yeah it like
sprayed and um I'm like totally naked
I'm like [__] this so that the door is
shut I kick that [__] well open
boom and then I see Wonka and Cody there
you know what I'm saying and they're
like down down this long aisle of the
bus cuz people sleep on the bus like
that and they're both both like what the
[__] you know I'm I'm naked there and I
I I'm very very specific I go you know
sometimes you like don't call 91 you
don't you know 911 scary you know police
sure yet a minute not this not this time
I said [__] call
911 I SLP my wrist wide [__] open
call 911 I SLP my wrist open and then
there was and are you still at the venue
at this point or the bus on the road now
but I mean are you rolling okay you're
still in the still loading out [__] um
and so and then they just like their
eyes their faces they're it so innocent
but wide open eyes like huh what you
know like T it seemed like forever going
by I'm like did you hear what the [__] I
just said I'm like go and they're like
what do you mean what and I had to
repeat myself like dude call 911 right
now I slit my my wrist is slit wide open
and they're like and poor Wonka man
bless his heart dude he is so bad at um
just like Crisis situations dude he he
is scared of everything you know what
I'm saying like this [__] slow down he's
like it's sped up it's sped up he was
like I I looked him in the eye and said
call 911 how many times did you say it
twice three times three times yeah and
you know they see me naked it's like
well you know it's a lot the process you
kick the door open you could be doing
some funny [__] you're naked they
thought it was like a prank you know my
dick's out and everything but
um yeah eventually they were like oh
[__] you know and so
Wonka's the the worst at a crisis
situation and then you got Cody who's
like the opposite he he's like probably
the worst in the different like he's
like the boy scout you know what I'm
saying he had he came running with the
tourniquet and [__] and he's like he's
tying it up all high and I'm like no
dude I want to keep my elbow I'm like
you don't need to [__] you don't need
to put it whole arm for the
wrist I'm like not up there dude I want
to keep my my neck why you put it on my
neck like he's like no let's do this
with a with a apple cord you know what
I'm saying I'm like oh Jesus Christ man
but that was a that was after a while so
I look at won I'm like call 911 this
[__] doesn't call 911 he he he
runs off the bus and he he uh he uh he
goes to the tour manager which takes an
additional two or three minutes to like
find her and have her come back and
she's got the balls to call 911 so Wonka
I'm talking to him and he's like man
honestly like I wouldn't even he was
like I would have slipped down fell
under my blood and like face facetimed
my daughter and said goodbye like like
that that was his plan he was like
that's exactly what would happen I would
have facetimed my daughter and said
goodbye and I [__] passed out so I'm
sitting there like this and I'm I'm
grabbing it as hard as I can my wrist
like have you looked at it yet again I
mean oh hell no there's nothing that's
going to [__] take you're not taking
it all I'm I'm I'm I'm squeezing as hard
like my life dependent on it because it
obviously did so you know Cody's doing
this thing and we got 911 on the phone
now we got the tour manager on the bus
and stuff Cody put my some shorts on me
which is cool you know what I'm saying
so everybody didn't have to look at my
dick the whole time is there are there
no paramedics on site at the venue or
anything like no one can come over over
and don't they legally have to have
somebody there for some [__] I don't
know but I mean people have seizures and
[__] you know like all the time because
of lights and stuff and there's been
people who pass out and stuff and like
we've been having them drop out my shows
we had a handful of Mario left right for
real dude for real it's all like I don't
know there's there was no one no one
there so how long does it take the
ambulance to get to the bus man it Fel
it felt like a quite a while um and
you're just holding it yeah yeah well we
were on the phone with
911 and the paramedics were like well
take your hand off uh uh they I said
[__] no they're like then you get a
towel do this I'm like I'm not taking my
hand off like my the the the cut hand
was turning purple I was it was I was
losing all it blood to it I was bro I
was I was holding as tight as I could
this this arm was like shaking because I
was like after like 15 minutes of as
hard as I possibly can you know know
what I'm saying like are you starting to
feel lightheaded or anything like that
I'm not losing any blood nothing not I
am squeezing hard as [__] I'm that I
mean like a tourniquet basically like
blood is not coming in or out and
they're like well let's you know want to
check your wrist to see what the damage
is I'm like I saw that [__] and they
were like they they they told me I was
like no I ain't doing that they're like
oh okay I'm like I'm not taking my
[__] hand off so I didn't and then
the paramedics came and um that was
iffy you know you mean they had to that
that was the first time where they're
like you know they need to take it off
need to take it off yeah so what
happened so there's like I think it's on
my Facebook or something there's there's
video of me like like like like um
grimacing or whatever and um them
looking at it and I I just I was like H
I felt like that was a pretty scary
moment um and then they looked at it
real quick put it you know then they put
some more [__] on it and you know you
catch gby jell look like they they were
like I didn't I didn't want I didn't
want to look at it again you know what
I'm saying but like all the people were
around me my tour crew and everything
and there was a couple like oh like cuz
everybody seeing it for the first time
oh this is worse it was it was it was it
was quiet and then a lot of people kind
of were like who we suing water pick who
we suing bro who wecking whatever I
don't know man Prevost the tour bus who
we suing bro probably the showerhead
company that's what I'm saying water
pick who is it sun be who we
suing um but the uh the bills were like
nothing which was awesome I think uh so
what happens they take you to the
hospital then so here's a really dumb
thing that I
did I was
like this is really I'm almost a ashamed
to say this they they were like all
right so let's go to the hospital I was
like how much how much n so stupid
they're like well it'll be like two
grand for the ride it's not stupid cuz
this is every what every
that's that's stupid though you know
what I'm saying you should not have to
be like
oh my life depended on it and I I took
my negotiate no you did not get get the
[__] put a coupon on your life bro get
the [__] I can afford that [__] too
that's so stupid listen I don't care
what I wanted to save a couple bucks
every human being could figure out how
to get $2,500 if it me a ride to the
hospital to save their life figure it
out so stupid so so you really take the
bus we speed do they give you a an
escort charge a half how do you get up
there they so when I I should have
arrived uh at the with the ambulance in
there because the Grady trauma unit
downtown Atlanta like they they got the
call they knew I was coming you know
what I'm saying I and so instead of
arriving in a [__] ambulance and
being shipped right away to the plastic
surgeon and [__] I get dropped off and
this huge waiting room Lobby and I'm
still holding my [__] wrist so I mean
this got to be 20 minutes since I've
[__] cut it and I'm looking at
there's hundreds of people in the lobby
all on drugs and [__] people moaning
laying on the floor and [__] now I'm I'm
waiting in line of hey uh my name is you
know D okay have a
seat and I sit down and I'm like I'm
gonna [__]
die everybody else is like rolling
around too like dying or whatever but
I'm like I I I can't I can't [__]
wait six hours sitting here I can't like
my hand was cramping and [__] you know
what I'm saying I'm like I can't do this
[__] they call me right away you know
what I'm saying cuz they if they didn't
you just got to go up and take that hand
off just spray it think I'm going need
to be SE
yeah yeah just take me my just I just
got a question I can only like do that
once
though so they take you back they take
me right they call my name like right
away cuz they they knew I was there they
wait on me that they like the plastic
surgeon um woke up that to in the middle
of the night to come you know meet me
there and [__] um and so they take me
back there and man the gry trauma unit
in
Atlanta one of the most traumatizing
[__] places I've ever been in my life
and it was Saturday night Saturday
morning drinking everyone was dying
everyone was dying around me every room
was full I was in a um the hallway
outside of you know the dude right next
to me um was on fentol or something like
that he J fell off of a [__] building
and he was all
crushed moaning and stuff and then and
I'm listening and I'm listening to
people we're like oh we got the man got
attacked by baseball bat you know his
head's up you know oh he died boom
people running around and I'm just
like just like a tear just comes down my
face and I'm just like but I Ain really
crying you know cuz I ain't no [__] the
tier was just I had no control over it
you know I'm just kidding but so they
put me in the [__] hallway and um
they they see me right away like they
are amazing like I want to thank the
Grady trauma unit like they were they
they were amazing um the hardest part of
the
entire thing was when they had to check
it the dude comes um up to me the doctor
he's putting on his gloves and it hurt
it Hur hurt like it hurt a lot sting it
was like it it was it this it did Sting
but the it was like I got I felt like I
got hit with a baseball bat in that area
it was real tender like even from like
here down like and it hurt and so um
dude goes we we need to see what we're
dealing with see if the arteries cut
obviously you know what I'm saying and
then so he comes up and then all these
other nurses start surrounding him and
me and there's like six to eight people
now and I'm like back in my chair and
I'm like what's going on and he was like
this is going to hurt I need to I need
to you know with his hands he needs to
open it up spread things around and look
at it [__] and I'm like okay he's going
to put his fingers in there yeah put
give me a the Nova cane in and they're
like no time no time I'm like give me a
pill give me a they're like that no time
they were like bro this is dead dead ass
serious about this they were like bite
down on this tow there's a tow here I
like and then people start to like come
around and stuff like they all insurance
though they're going to hold me they're
going to hold me down like you're some
Civil War V bro I thought this was like
what the [__] is this the Middle Ages
like Dark Ages with insurance this is
what we deal with yeah I'm I'm like give
me a no numb me up or something they
telling you now no we need to do this
right we need this right now which I was
like okay okay [__] it makes sense I
guess you know
saying so they [__] put a towel in my
mouth and then they put a towel over my
head and I'm sitting back there like
this like and then they're starting to
grab my arms and stuff so I don't like
shake and everything and that
[__] that was that was wor how long's
he digging in there felt like it felt
for like forever is he trying to make
sure everything's not like sever he was
he was taking things and moving them
around wide open on my inside blood and
everything's just pumping yeah no well
luckily my uh artery wasn't slit so
there was there was blood from other
things but it wasn't like full like that
but he is moving like let me see your
wrist so imagine he was doing this but
on the inside like oh yeah moving that
to the side moving this moving out the
way looking at other things and [__]
like that with his [__] hands just
woke up with those middle of the night
eyes and [__] too
I was
like they're like you're doing good
you're doing good and I'm like you know
I wasn't like screaming or anything but
I was like definitely moaning and uh
that [__] was really tough so then what
does he have to do is that sewed up so
uh stapled what happened this is how
close it was
um they so I had damage um just um more
so than just the skin but barely any so
in an artery
there's an artery there's tendons and
the they have sheaths over them so they
they have like these Coatings I split
the sheath to my artery and and the
sheath to a bunch of tendons but I
didn't split the actual artery so I only
learn I learned about that from my back
surgery like my nerves were uh all that
coating was gone yeah so does that grow
back I don't know they put me on my way
man that they had they were busy so you
know once they once they figured out um
that I wasn't uh didn't have my artery
slit they were like all right you're
going to wait for a long time you know
what I'm saying so I I I waited there
for you know probably four or five hours
cuz [__] was going down in there man
gunshots coming in I was just sitting
watching it all blood everywhere on the
floor people were just hustling dude it
was crazy and what do they do they
Stitch that up how do they heal how do
they do that they Stitch liquid [__] or
old school Stitch old school it was too
big to could they give you Novae or
something for that did they did know
that you know um someone and did it
still hurt that's a weird spot to be
getting stitched up just thinking in my
mind like looking at my oh [__] it hurt
and then the next couple days yeah um
but it was funny like uh the Doctor Who
was digging at me recognized me and he
was like telling all the people and like
I heard my music bumping in some rooms
and stuff like they started playing me
and like I knew they were like watching
music videos and stuff so like I usually
I don't like getting recognized but I
was like they're going to yeah so all of
the [__] uh the doctors and stuff
wanted to come by and see me and they
were all like dude you you're so lucky
dude and he oh this is the hand guy bro
you you are so lucky you are so lucky so
after they recognize me and play my
music and I told them I had to like tell
them the exact story because they
thought it was suicidal when I first
came in and so did they believe it yeah
they're like I'm look I'm on tour you
know they're like oh yeah that's Prof
like they were listening to my music and
[__] and then I'm like yeah this I'm on
the tour bus this is how it happened and
dude knew me for he was a fan um the S
the surgeon who came in and um so he
knew he like followed me he knew I was
he was like he's fine you know
so yeah and they stitched me up and sent
me on my way but I saw some crazy [__]
in there man I'm like I'm very very
thankful yeah for the for these people
dude they see this [__] every night I'm
like the worst I mean no offense yours
is terrible mine was bad too it ain't
the worst they're seeing yeah you know
what I'm saying the dude the dude in uh
next to me what I had to listen to was
they were like hey it's going to get
loud in there we have to bring out the
drill and they cuz the dude was just uh
his hips were just crushed and his bones
were crushed and they were trying to ask
him his name [__] loud in there and like
we gave him ketamine and it's going to
be an outer body experience but um he's
gonna he's going to start
screaming it's like this is this is
crazy man there's some saints man they
deal with
the worst [__] you know and that's
that's a famous place like you go look
up Grady trauma unit downtown Atlanta
like it are you lucky you were at a
place that was so good are you lucky you
weren on the road literally and took
that shower in the middle of [__] bum
[__] nowhere mhm yeah I was downtown
Atlanta do you still shower after your
shows now or do you wait till you're I
know I still do you do mhm so I wanted I
was saying this to Kirsten I was like
imagine this is the [__] that was going
through my mind while I'm laying there
watch watching your stuff play out on
social media I was like imagine being
you or anyone but you specifically
obviously for this and you've chased
your whole dreams you've set your whole
life and everything in your [__]
fiber in motion to accomplish this goal
and you you're there and now you're on
the tour bus and you're living life and
Are you seriously telling me that a
[__] showerhead could ruin it
all the one thing that you've wanted all
your life and you get there and then
it's the thing that could kill you like
[__] had thinking about I was depressed
for a while yeah I had I was depressed
for a while for like a week afterwards I
just had this dark feeling like holy
[__] we're vulnerable we could trip and
fall and die you know anytime a [__]
jet engine could fall out the sky and
like you know [__] like that happens you
know like it's funny Brandy said to me
she's like do you think you'll podcast
forever and I go well I'm I'm no longer
saying anything forever I don't do that
[__] I said but here's the thing I don't
think I will but if I would have just
died technically I podcasted forever you
know what I'm saying so I don't know if
I die next year I podcast it forever my
forever yeah yeah that's like that joke
that's like man if I save know my
finances are good enough where I could
retire and live pretty well if I die on
Monday yeah exactly L right yeah yeah
there's one question to ask if you're
shopping for someone who already has
everything do they still wipe their butt
I'm a huge fan of my hello Toshi bedet
all right I've been using one for years
for years it's my favorite thing I don't
like to go poop anywhere else I will
hold it just to get home it makes me
feel clean it makes me feel fresh I
don't even like going on the road
anymore at these hotels all right with
over 100,000 festar reviews see why
millions of real pooping humans already
love hello tushi bedet every hello tushi
B attachment comes with a 30-day
risk-free guarantee and a 12 month
warranty hello tushy Beday fresh stream
of water cleans your bum two times
better than wiping even if you're using
wet wipes you're still just smearing
poop around and you're introducing nasty
chemicals to your butt using a hello
tushi bedet also prevents poo particles
from spreading to your hands and
everything you touch it attaches to your
existing toilet requires no electricity
or additional plumbing and cuts toilet
paper use by 80% a hello tushi bedet
pays for itself in under a year shop
from your toilet this brown Friday and
save up the 30% on B days and bundles
visit hellotushy.com
honeydo and use promo code honeydew for
30% off your first order that's
hellotushy.com
honeydo for 30% off now through November
25th the farmer's dog was founded by two
dog lovers who decided to reimagine pet
food from the ground up the results of
switching your dogs food from kibble to
Fresh can seem like magic when a senior
dog starts acting young again or a picky
eater now can't wait for dinner time you
might think some spells were cast The
Farmer's dog makes and delivers fresh
healthy dog food it's developed by vets
nutritionally balanced and made from
real healthy ingredients to human food
safety standards it's the best option
for dogs
at all life stages because it's not
kibble it's not canang goo it's just
real healthy food traditional dry and
wet dog food options are highly
processed they can use much lower
quality ingredients than they claim to
and they are extremely difficult to
portion accurately it doesn't matter if
your dog is young or old it's always the
right time to begin investing in their
health helping you live more healthy
happy and full years together give 50%
off your first box of fresh healthy food
at thefarmersdog.com honeydo Plus you
get free shipping just go to
thefarmersdog.com honeydew to get 50%
off that's
thefarmersdog.com
honeydew now let's get back to the D man
I thought about that and I was like God
you chasing your whole dream and then
something is dumb as a showerhead
leaking showerhead and the [__] I got
away with the [__] I got away with bro I
was jumping off garage getting drunk and
climbing trees and get past 16 is
amazing the stuff we all do as kids and
[__] uh and that almost you said 16 that
was more like 33 for me when that [__]
stopped I was doing I was doing that
[__] well you know well in about 33 I
was doing dumb [__] man well have you
slowed down since this is that something
that made you start thinking about that
I know I know you were just fixing a
leaking shower head but has it made you
think about slowing down and and really
are uh like you said we're so vulnerable
we nothing I kind of already was you
know what I'm saying just getting more
wise um but this isn't really you know
stopping much is that one do you hold
the mic in that hand a lot my mic hand y
it isuh has it has it do you wear a
guard or anything is it I did I did for
that whole tour and then um I couldn't
um I had meet and greets and I couldn't
um the doctor was like d don't be
touching [__] a thousand people a day
don't touch nobody and so um you know I
put a WAP over it and I didn't I didn't
I should have went home and had it seen
and had and rehabbed it right um because
like you know now my thumb is all [__]
up and like you know what I'm saying um
things are a little crazy look at that
that's wild dude yeah um so what I
getting
to oh yeah so you know um taped it up
the crazy part was the first show back I
stayed on the road and I had two days
off right after that [__] to to recoup
which was like perfect um but you're
aggressive man you dive out into the
crowd you're not worried about hitting
that on somebody or some [__]
stopped for sure like I stayed you know
and how you keeping it clean and yeah
yeah so we we uh we tried our best we
got that like that that clear sheet
thing that people put over like tattoos
and [__] and um what the first show back
I didn't know what to expect and um if I
would have popped stitches and [__] like
that I'd have probably canceled stuff
and just flew back home um and Rehab but
and you know when that first show I did
it adrenaline going crazy and then you
know Wonka was like my work my nurse
with me and [__] and we just like
unwrapped it and looked at it we're like
here we go you know and it was like so
still so w it was the first time you saw
it yeah it's all white and [__] yeah and
it just the skin didn't look like it was
together it just
looked it was still [__] wide open
you know what I mean it wasn't you know
those first couple shows back it
was it was it wasn't how you feeling now
though you have full flexibility do
everything you know you have feeling in
it yeah um I'm I have to like massage it
I'm supposed to massage it so it doesn't
get like scar tissue and stuff and that
kind of hurts but um you know like I'm
at home I'm doing pull-ups again and
stuff but um I'm using it took it took
about a month or whatever but uh it's
not like your [__] or like back like it
was mostly skin and a little bit of
tissue you know nerves and [__] I was
right back in it though yeah like just a
few days I was lucky yeah and i i i i t
I continued the whole tour didn't miss a
[__] show so I was lucky man really
lucky so I wanted I saw we had some
stuff up here on this uh on this monitor
about stuff on your tour tell me about
somebody snuck on your bus oh yeah I
wasn't there so this is a just Word of
Mouth from my
driver I was just sitting out there with
the bus the whole time yeah yeah the
driver's sleeping on the bus they had
their own little
bunk I'm doing the show inside he
sleeping the bus is locked I mean I
guess he didn't lock his door to the cab
he he stays he lives in the cab or
whatever
but a schizophrenic woman I hope she
doesn't like she listen listen to
this [__] whatever man um listen she
made a decision yeah and I'm not really
too familiar with schizophrenia so like
I don't I don't I don't know man but she
broke have a cousin who's schizophrenic
so I know all right am I in danger
telling this story then no I mean look I
I can't say schizophrenics aren't
dangerous but the ones I've dealt with
haven't been they're just not mentally
well yeah they don't really do they
break into tour buses and demand to see
people and stuff that one that one might
be a problem yeah I didn't know there
were demands she got into this dude's
sleeping and he wakes up to a stranger
she's in the cat she's in she goes into
his bunk into his
bed I know what the [__] what the [__]
who are you you know what I'm saying
he's in his boxes and [__] he's like who
what what's going on you know and um
she's like take me to Prof take me to
Prof I got to see him he's uh he needs
to apologize to me you know what I'm
saying he's been breaking into my house
and putting up cameras all around my
house he need you know I demand an
apology I got to see him and so that's
that's what she was talking about so and
then he you know he got up he's like get
the [__] off this bus boom boom boom and
he kind of like knew figured out like I
I can't
reason you know I got to I got to be
clever around this so he like dances
around the situation and kind of like
come on let's get off of the bus and so
he gets her off the bus and um at that
point I think there's like security that
sees things now that because you know
that they see what's going on and uh
this was at the White Oak in Houston
Houston um White Oak great venue I'm
performing there um
November um so very thankful and the the
uh security came she she grabbed a
bottle and then it heated up again and
threw a bottle at him smashed B bottle
you know Jagged edges and [__] and um we
had enough Jagged edges on this goddamn
tour dude oh yeah I wonder if that was
the same tour when I was hurting I think
it was earlier but um yeah bro so yeah I
I don't really I wasn't there so that
was only some secondhand [__]
but he he handled it pretty well and you
never seen her again again she hit you
up on social and stuff I've never seen
her I don't know who she is like you
know I don't like to like study and and
like look up things or people or
anything like that like even people
hating on me or whatever I'm like don't
tell me about it you know what I'm
saying my crew my crew is like oh look
at this someone saw this so they'll hit
me up like oh my bad man this guy's
talking [__] like I don't don't tell me
about it yeah that's my new [__] not
getting into that petty [__] you know
yeah tell me about this uh that body in
La what's this oh yeah I figured man
like I haven't told you about this like
this was a class here's the other thing
the last time you came on you're telling
me this whole [__] story I'm like
when was this you're like this was
flying here Ryan I was like wait that
happened to you on the way here you're
like man I was just thinking about that
the other day man like I can't [__]
believe they they gave me back my acid
and my [__] and the box cutter right
yeah who you go here like I'm like this
[__] must have been stupid I
think he was maybe out uh it was like a
arts and crafts thing or something paper
cutting or something I don't know maybe
I didn't think you would ever fly with a
box cutter [__] no ever he took out the
blade and gave me the box cutter and a
bag of acid back he was have fun can't F
I was so red dog I can't believe that
[__] I was just thinking about that
[__] um what the hell oh yeah dead body
in La yeah uh this is um a while ago I'm
with my my friends and stuff and he's in
a uh Town town home and he you know he
shares a wall with a elderly man and so
we we partying and [__] We're Young
stallions you know and um we're about to
go out and we're like pre- partying or
some pregaming is what they call it and
um there's a a closet I go into for to
get something or whatever I'm like oh
[__] that this closet is hot as hell and
I'm like why is this closet hot dude
he's like I don't know my you know was
probably something with my neighbor and
[__] I'm like that was weird that's a
clue get your head spinning so I ignore
it whatever we keep drinking or whatever
and then
um about an hour later we're about to
we're all we're all headed out and um I
look in the in the window of his
neighbor's spot or or I think I touched
the wall or something I'm like it's
[__] hot in here like what the hell
and I see I like peek over my [__] and I
was getting kind of like you know little
the yeah like I was just too curious I
like jump the fence and look through
this dude's
window all of the [__] burners were
on it was it was into his kitchen all of
the burners were all the way on all the
way
up and I'm like what the [__] that that
that's why it's hot you know what I'm
saying how how long has this been that
was a like an hour ago two hours ago I
felt it was a hot closet I'm like this
is this is crazy and and I'm looking
over there wide window and then I just
go I look down and there's a dead man
you know in a pile of [__] and blood and
he's got blood yeah and he's got I don't
know if it was blood or sh [__] maybe
both it was red [__] blood was it
suicide like are you also you endanger a
light in a m and blowing up cuz his gas
is just pumping on too I don't know what
the [__] is going on so and he's got his
like shirt over his
head where I'm thinking like did he hang
himself cuz and then the chair was there
too like everything was gas himself out
in there everything was so [__] weird
the dude was old as hell and his his
shirt was up so I could see his rib cage
and [__] huge rib cage and like sunk in
in body like dude was old M and so I'm
like What's call 911 you know what I'm
saying and did they do it right away
they they run out and get security bro I
did I called 911 you can't trust you
can't trust Wonka
dude you call 911 and they come out and
the dude's just no I call 911 it goes uh
we're busy leave a message nuh yes I
didn't even know that [__] was possible
I have absolutely call 911 out here and
they tell you to hold and then and then
if you don't know this is what I didn't
know I found out later you're just
transferred to the CHP the California
Highway Patrol they'll just kick you
over to them like what's your emergency
you say this they just kick you over to
them you're like what the [__] they were
like leave a message I want to listen to
my I wish I could find my message leave
a message and we'll get back to you I'm
like this is is this did I dial the
wrong [__] number like this is funny
so I'm like I'm like um
hello oh there's a dead
body my name is d uh we we got to
there's someone's here is dead call me
back you know so I'm like now we got to
wait here you know what I'm saying they
they hit me up what's going on you know
can you uh uh go in there and um give
him CPR and [__] I'm
like I'm like no this motherfucker's
dead man I'm not they're like no you got
to check his pulse or at least something
and you know break in there break a
window whatever I'm like he gone bro
like nah um I'm not touching no it's
[__] it smells it smells awful and stuff
like I'm not doing that [__] so and it's
been cooking in there too man dog yeah
it's cooking [__] and so the [__] the
the the firefighters get there first and
they're so stupid they're so stupid this
dude is passed out in a kitchen in front
of the
door and and I'm I'm just like right in
there like in their business I'm like
yeah it looks like you know I'm you know
and uh they're like kick kick down the
door and I'm like no man no no no cuz if
you kick this door it they could they
wanted to save him they wanted to take
his Poli or you know perhaps Save
Somebody they they couldn't
[__] tell he was dead you know what
I'm saying but anyway so I'm like if you
kick that door I'll tell him he's it
that it's going to hit his head if you
want to save him you can't you got to go
through the window and he just looked at
me like whatever [__]
wow he kicked his door so
hard I'm looking through the window this
dude's body goes
flying flying spinning around like a
[__] top like a [__] rag
doll like a rag doll and I'm like well
if he wasn't dead before he [__] sure
is now dead now bro [__]
genius oh [__] you think just because
like people are in charge like or like
if they're a policeman that they should
be just and fair or that they're a fir
fighter that they should be smart or
Brave n these people people are [__]
idiots I say all the time about doctors
you know what they called a person to
finish last in med school doctor that
[__] finished last he or she is
still a doctor the mean anything yeah is
that your first time seeing a dead body
nah man I've seen PL I've seen what's
your first time plenty of those what's
your first time I think we talked about
and I don't mean a funeral either I mean
like that oh yeah I've seen my dad my
dad dead dad that was interesting but
that's funeral [__] um uh my first time
seen a dead body was I don't think you
ever told me about that did
you seeing your dad dead like that laid
out yeah we talked about that no he in
the casket yeah I you mean yeah that was
weird was that the first time you seen a
body prepared and laid out like that too
no grandparents and [__] grandparents
but um grand grand my grandparents
always looked a little weird because
they were just older and the way they
just [__] I'm like that ain't him
nobody looks like out yeah but I was
like man you did a good job with my dad
you know what I'm saying cuz he was
younger but um yeah that was weird that
funeral sucked I like just sucks like
sitting in the front you know
everybody's watching you know I'm Paul
Bear and [__] and then the whole
everybody's just watching me sit down
with my stepmom with my mom and [__] I'm
F yeah I've carried so many caskets
through the hole man I can't even tell
you well I have a whole bit about being
a Paul Bearer cuz I learned quick that
you need to get the foot end of that
casket you know what I'm saying that
that's the light part back here with the
feet you get up you get up there you're
up there double handing if you got the
I'll take that I made that mistake
before you ever got to anybody out there
R to carry a casket get where the ask
them where the shoes are get that in if
you ever look around the casket they're
like man you ain't doing work I'm doing
the [__] work here though you see
somebody doing two hands get it come on
man waving like what the [__] you you
know what I'm saying I'm like [__] this
is heavy casets are heavy as hell it's
heavy as [__] yeah they need eight man
to be doing that heavy and then you got
to Str going to get it up on the rollers
in the her everybody's doing everything
they can not to drop that thing you
can't drop a [__] casket but yeah my
first body was a uh drive by getting
dropped off the uh from the bus in the
middle of the day how old are you uh
maybe first or second grade Jesus
yeah you're outside when it's going down
I'm no I'm in a school bus and and and
it's my stop yeah so the school
bus open I'm like oh Ste out right into
a [__] drive by right into a gunfight
you know what I'm saying you see the guy
get out yeah there was uh three three
dead um right there so we just blood all
over the on the corner right on the
corner Jesus yeah I was interviewed for
um by the
uh the news as a kid station yeah I
wonder if that's in there yeah me and my
sister my sister was on the school they
asking kids hey man [__] gruesome huh
traumatizing hey bus 88o repres
he no but that's that's what I was used
to man if I would to see uh uh shootout
now and [__] you know like I'd be like
oh no but back then I was like yeah you
know I'm listening to rap music and [__]
and like I'm like man I live in a hood
man this is crazy you know like um it
was like normal was it that's what I
want to ask you did it become normal for
you yeah yeah like how of like I almost
took pride in that [__] like yeah yeah
now I can go to school and say that I'm
tough and [__] you know but now I'd be
[__] terrified i' be like oh no my
wrist
my call 911 yeah call 91 man boy it
changes doesn't it yeah I haven't seen a
shootout in a minute oh actually I'm
lying I saw [__] lots of shootouts in
2020 oh yeah during the pandemic during
the pandemic I lived I lived uh that's
right you live right there by the riots
[__] 500 feet from the [__] third
precinct which people chased the damn
police out of the building
[__] Remember the Alamo so I live
right there so my I mean there was a
helicopter blackhaw helicopter above my
house for the whole summer you know what
I'm saying so but I was taking a bath in
a claw foot tub I was just chilling and
I sound safer in a shower y yo so so and
I'm just I'm just like it was like what
what just uh taking care of yourself
what is that called these days you know
what I'm saying self self care you know
I'm just yeah you know painting my nails
or whatever but I'm in a bathtub and my
alley
po return fire boom fire fire first time
ever I heard these [__]
reload yeah I'm like they're [__]
reloading and I was I was going to get
up or whatever but I'm like oh I'm
chilling in this bathtub so I just sat
had a bath and and just listen Len to
listen to a gight just listen to a
[__] prolonged gun fight it was like
5 six minutes they were they were like
reloading like all right here's the
break I'm like I'm counting rounds I'm
like these [__] is really
thinking about this this isn't you know
they're ducking behind things or
whatever yeah that was that was wild it
was that was a crazy summer man yeah I
never seen knock almost say knock I've
seen plenty of guns I've seen plenty of
people pull them out I've never seen a
shootout though never I saw a few that
summer you did yeah I mean all there in
Minneapolis yeah yeah a lot of my
friends Cody outside like um he was like
me [__] we were all we all got
guns and like in my house I like I
[__] I had a
pistol stack of hollow tip bullets man
you know what I'm saying like we all got
guns and we all were like running around
trying to protect places and [__] and
there was shoot like crazy ass races
came in and was like we're going to do
damage and so like there like every
night there was it shootouts Wild West
there was no police like if you want to
steal some [__] you know I got video
just like recording people like I lived
right by that Target and it was just
like line like the neighborhood filled
up with cars you couldn't even find a
forg Target Minneapolis head yeah yeah
so like I don't know everybody came in
you want to be an arsonist like there it
is there was a I live by a bank they
robbed that bank for like hours and
hours they brought dynamite and [__]
Dynamite they were like if hey
professional bank robbers if you if you
a professional bank robber in the
Midwest and you know that this this
place is burning or whatever like all
right well take get in the car like I
got some [__] to do no no one got you
know everyone was getting away with
everything there people hang hanging out
of [__] SUVs doing donuts just
shooting guns in the air All Summer Long
like that's just what it was wow mhm
tell me about some of these accidents
you've been in some car accidents this
just happened like a month ago are you
serious yeah two months not not my
accident I I tried to save a lady right
so speaking of dumbass [__]
this dude had the same DNA as this uh
firefighter so I was wondering you're
going okay yeah I am I'm driving and I
just see something we weird the
intersection is something's off and I I
go around a car and I'm like oh [__]
this just happened here I didn't see it
happen but there's a car you know on its
side and no one's there yet and I'm like
oh [__] and um I'm a hero so I like to
just Dive Right In you know and um
actually I've say you get excited when
you see [__] like this like here's my
chance I go no I'm not ex I I just go go
towards it I go like if I'm even if I'm
afraid if there's someone in my house
like I'm not saying I'm brave I'm saying
I'm terrified where I need to handle it
like if I think someone's in my house I
got to get a knife and I'm going right
at it you know what I'm saying because
I'm because I'm scared you know so I I I
pull pull my whip over I run up to her
and I'm the first one there and there's
a um on that corner there's a uh Car
Wash and it's
cracking and I'm looking at this
lady ter terrified old lady hanging like
this but she's got her she's got her
seat Bel on and I'm looking at her and I
go up to her i'm like [__] what's up no
I look at her I'm like are you
okay hey dumbass [__] how did you what
you no I'm looking at her I'm
like are you okay and she's she goes
yeah I'm I'm all right and I'm like okay
and she's on her side she's on the side
she's hanging is is the passenger side
on the ground and and her she's the
driver side and she's up she's up she so
it would be it would be this way yep I
got you yeah so and she's like I'm okay
I'm okay I'm like all right and I'm
talking to her through the glass and
then out of nowhere I hear
like and and he dude just runs up to
this [__] thing and just starts
smashing his elbow into the window b b
bow I'm like what the [__] are you doing
man he's like we got to break this glass
I'm like she's fine she's right behind
the window you're going to break the
glass on her and and then people at the
car wash big big ass men they all get
excited and they all come running I'm
like don't do that and she's like don't
do it and he smashes the
window [__] glass all over her you
know what I'm saying I'm like and she's
like ah stop I'm like the I'm like and
I'm trying to talk to him and all these
dudes come together and they're like
let's flip the car and I'm like n we
could just let's talk about this I could
probably just open the door [__] [__]
it start they start rolling this car
over I just go like this I'm like all
right I just leave while they're [__]
rolling so they're rolling a car like
this and I'm like what if it rolls the
oppos you know they're trying to get
momentum it could roll back on you
whatever and I'm like these these dudes
they ain't hearing [__] I'm like I'm out
of here man get right back in my car and
just drive away while they're [__]
probably smashing the lady around and
[__] so it was cool and then another one
that um I forgot about till the homies
um uh brought it up was we were driving
through Canada on tour through the
Canadian
Rockies and
uh and um we [__] run out of gas like
in a long stretch long ass stretch we we
[__] up and um so
we're we we just go off like that and
while really weird coincidence while we
run out of gas and pull over
a car flips and smashes and crashes yeah
we're like what the [__] like we all
like oh no and then we look back and
there's this smash car on on the
opposite end of the lane and so homie of
mine uh finding novon another rapper who
was on tour with me we jumped the lanes
and it was kind of a busy freeway for uh
for how remote it was and um we're
running towards his car and unlike this
other one with this lady like I can see
it's not that bad she barely you know
this one's like Smash and I'm like I'm
running up to this car I'm like are you
ready to see some [__] you know like you
run up to a car I'm like [__] I'm going
to see some [__] you know I don't know I
don't know what to see and uh we get up
there and I'm looking on uh underneath
and it's like a whole family you know
what I'm saying and with with a daughter
and everything and they're they're not
out yet um the windows are smashed and
one guy's coming out but um uh we we I'm
a hero so I help the uh the girl out and
the guy out and the the mother and
everything they were shaking up were
they good they were good and I'm like
like they were crying hysteric you do
like swerved from a deer or something
like what the hell made him flip like
that it was it was it it had snowed and
so there was like patches of snow and
[__] and then that black ice bro yeah
but they were like I was like are you
guys all three of you are okay they're
like yeah I'm like then [__] this like
like that's all that matters you know
what I'm saying and so then I just uh
let my Cape unfurl and I I flew away
You're long hair was like you guys safe
okay all right yeah and then I flew
away um look I want to ask you about
this cuz I I find
myself I don't know I'm I feel like
we're the same and like all right this
[__] happened it's over let's let's move
forward but I've been finding pockets of
it coming back to affect me that I
didn't expect I had a guest on and he
was driving he
clots and it almost kills him and they
kept telling me you don't understand how
lucky you are and you don't understand
how lucky you are that you're here you
weren't out there yeah cuz they were
going to send me home the day before and
I said to them man if you all would have
sent me home I'm definitely calling 911
for this and they're saying like yeah
but you ain't making it it you ain't
making it paramedics don't know how to
they they're just going to keep you
comfortable and get your vitals and
stuff enough to get you there where they
need to you know what I mean and that
might not be enough time so this guy is
starting to talk to me about how he
almost died from it I'm like like damn I
really am [__] lucky to be alive has
it starting to hit you at all like
you're a dad too uhhuh are you you
thinking about the kids you think about
when I was sitting in the uh in the
trauma unit I was thinking oh [__] just
about them really and you know I've been
I've been you know [__] uh I'm a
thinking man I think you know I think
about death you know what I'm saying and
it's just how old are you now I'm
23 you got a long way to go bro you know
what I'm saying we can hear you laughing
out there
[__] um but yeah uh yeah I think
about that [__] and I'm you have two
kids is it two kids right cuz I want to
say the first time you on you or maybe
the second time you one yeah you have
one I'll be making I'll be [__] bro
yeah
[Laughter]
bro but I man I'm just just productively
[__] I just I just uh it's just
everything's so fleeting and fast that
I'm I just try and like enjoy this
miracle right now know I don't believe
there's an afterlife I think this is
what we get my brother and I talk about
this it just lights out when it's done I
think it's the most incredible but that
that for me that makes it even more
incredible we're floating around in
there galaxies there's galaxies on
Galaxies on Galaxies we're made up the
same atams somehow the atoms and and
everything whoosing around when and now
here I am out of that like that's so
[__] incredible um just beyond
like just it's mind-blowing I'm thankful
and just to be here is this is this is
the heaven we get man like what are the
[__] odds it's it's astronomical dude
you can't even think about it so it's
like just to be have the atoms come
together poof make me real quick boof
right back into the dust like I'm okay
with that you know you're the one person
too I talked about the gets it I feel
like what we do is as close to time
travel as we can be right now we get on
these tubes that are mechanical and and
fully programmed they take us to another
city in a different time zone we do this
job
on we're back and and it's like man what
the hell just I just went somewhere and
now I'm back home I feel like I'm living
two lives like I feel like I've always
been on tour but then I feel like I've
always been home when I come home I'm
like I never left I never toured and
when I'm touring I'm like I I've never
stopped this [__] like it it's really
[__] strange I feel like I've split
out two [__] hemispheres like it's
it's a weird feeling how often does it
cross your mind do you think about it
every time you get in the shower
this
[__] um no there was there was there was
a shower on the same tour there was a
shower that was leaking and I I was like
and I I I reached no I reached in there
and I tightened it and I was like all
right you know like I I had to do that
you know I saw it I was like you need to
you need to twist this [__]
showerhead you know it was my heart was
beating you know what I'm saying um and
I [__] myself in but it was in the
shower that's just goes down the drain
bro know dude thank you for coming and
doing this show you're the [__] man an
hour already look at it holy [__] yeah
man you're a good time dude I'm so glad
we become friends and I'm again you
could have easily said [__] you Kiren
wasn't even working here the first time
mhm and I remember you were like I don't
want people to get fired I'm like
they're getting fired bro so uh thank
you for coming on and doing this man for
real um one more time again don't
promote anything you want what is it the
tour what's the tour called the tour is
going to be over I don't give a [__] man
all the shows are sold out anyways there
you
go [__] I'm coming to see you Saturday
night I make music I'm going to come see
you you're going to come see me Saturday
night man let's get I am LR is a great
spot you're going to love it you never
performed there huh I have I had I had a
a whole [__] icy thrown at my face
after the end of my set I said thank
you that's the last time I was at the LR
so I got to get I gotta I got to get
revenge
well thank you for coming on as always
brother uh and as always Ryan sickler on
all social media Ryan sikler doccom come
see me on tour tickets are available on
my website we'll talk to you all next
[Music]
[Applause]
week
m